- Wait, this is what it's
like when your show has money?
(audience laughs)
What?
There's like, so many lights inside.
- I love your set, actually.
That had made me wanna go on your show.
Are you gonna have
me on your show?
- Thank you.
Absolutely!
My set is the size of my
current greenroom on your stage.
- You know what, though?
But that's awesome 'cause
that kind of creates,
have you done "Andy Cohen Live"?
Like, it kind of creates
this whole atmosphere
where you're all together,
and it creates
kind of a different vibe.
- Right,
that's like the nice way.
That's a nice disclaimer
of being like, "It's small,
"it's cute, it's intimate."
- No, no!
I'm being real, 'cause
sometimes on big huge sets,
it can feel a little cold.
Like, our job was to warm it up,
we wanted to warm it up,
but I actually think
that's really important,
like about your show.
- Thank you.
- I think it creates more of
a cozy kind of environment
to where you really get to open up.
I love it.
- Well I appreciate that.
I do love it, don't get me wrong.
I do love it, it's just my greenroom
had like chocolates and stuff.
- You're hilarious.
(both laugh)
Well, last time we saw each other,
I think it'd been close to a month.
'Cause we both started at the same time.
- I know my sister right here, everybody.
This is my sister.
- Yes, yes!
I just need to say, your wins,
- We were texting.
- Your wins are my wins,
- Agreed.
- and I'm so happy for you,
and she's doing a great job,
and it was just so awesome to
be starting at the same time.
- It really was,
and it was really nice
to talk to another woman
that's in a very similar position,
and just us texting,
simply was kinda like, very refreshing.
- I remember texting you one day,
and I was having a
really overwhelming day,
and I thought, I bet you
Kelly could relate to this.
So I picked up the phone,
and I was like, "My one friend", whatever.
(Kelly laughs)
And I was like "Hey, how is it going?"
And we actually talked about
how we both just finished crying.
- Yes, yes.
That's a normal day that ends
in wine for me, but yeah.
- And then I always tell you
how I had no time to cry,
and I had the scheduled 10 minutes to cry,
because someone kept knocking on my door,
and I was like, "I'm crying!"
(audience laughs)
- Yeah, give me a minute!
- Give me a cry break!
So it was very refreshing.
- It is, I think because you
came from YouTube, right?
And so, what would you
say the difference is?
Like, because all your YouTube videos,
and going to now doing
the nighttime thing,
like, how different is that?
- Oh, it's so different.
I mean, on my YouTube
channel I control everything,
and there's a crew of five
people that work on my content.
And then I got a show, and y'all,
there's literally one hundred
people that work on my show.
There's probably 3000 here,
but 100 work on my show.
- No, there's about the same. (laughs)
- And they have all these
jobs that I'm, to be honest,
not familiar with.
- Me neither.
- So, someone will come up
to me, and they'll be like,
" I'm your script
supervisor", and I'm like.
And I'm like, "Way to go!"
(audience laughs)
- Scripts need supervision?
- Yeah,
yeah, I know, good job.
- I don't know what that means.
- I like the script, so well done.
- So many names.
- Yeah, I know.
- So, I call everyone my friend.
- It is cool though, how
you have this whole team
that kind of supports you,
and like,
- Absolutely.
- you know, lifts you up,
and makes your show really awesome.
I love it, I love having a crew.
- Late night staff, your talk show staff.
(audience cheers and applauds)
The staff really makes it.
- So, here's my thing with
your new deal, your new life.
- Okay, talk to me.
- Have you blown any money on
an indulgence of any sorts?
- Ooh, well you know, a
lot in my life has changed,
except for the fact that I'm very cheap.
(audience laughs)
And that will be consistent.
But there is one thing I splurge on.
I feel like it's very relatable, though.
The one thing I will splurge
on is birthday parties
for my dog.
(audience laughs)
I will spend
any amount of money on my dog.
- Does everyone relate?
She knows what I'm talking
about, she's like (clapping).
- I mean.
- She knows what I'm talking about.
On my dog!
- Not your birthday.
Not yours?
- Listen, on my birthday
I'll be up in a Denny's
just being casual, okay?
But my dog's birthday.
- Moons Over My Hammy.
- So, he recently turned two.
I know, they grow up so fast.
- Mine just turned two.
- Oh really?
- Henry, yeah.
- Well, we're the same.
- Yeah, we're the same human.
- My dog turned two,
and I gave him a Harry
Potter themed birthday.
(audience gasps and applauds)
- Yes.
- I love Harry Potter.
- Yes!
- "Have you seen this wizard?"
- And it took place in Dogwarts.
Thank you, thank you.
- Thank you, thank you. (laughs)
- I love Harry Potter as well.
- I mean, it was great.
All of his dog friends came.
I made all these cupcakes.
Look at him, he's dressed as a Gryffindor.
I mean, it's just a whole thing.
It's a whole thing.
- Oh my gosh, I love you.
- Thank you.
- That's so cute that you
spend your money on others.
- Oh, absolutely.
- I do the same, totally.
(audience laughs)
- I feel like I have
my priorities in check.
- Me too.
- I do.
- Mine are different, though.
(both laugh)
- I was like "Happy
birthday, Henry!", snuggle.
(laughter)
But you have an awesome
connection with your fans.
- Yes.
- And I actually love that about you,
and I think that's why you're successful.
And what is, maybe, your most fun,
or coolest kind of fan encounter?
- I mean, there's so many.
I really do genuinely
love my fans so much.
I mean, when you come
from the digital space,
you really understand that
there's no record label,
there was no one that's started
except for people just
supporting you online.
So those supporters are really responsible
for a lot of what I have,
and so I have so much love for them.
But one of the most
meaningful stories I think,
you know, earlier this year
when I came out online,
I remember I was really scared,
and it was before I had a trip to India.
And, you know, Indian
culture is quite taboo
when it comes to sexuality,
and I was so stressed going to India,
and I was like " Oh, what
are people gonna think?"
I don't know.
And I had a meet and greet,
and I met with 200 fans,
and honestly, I'd say about a hundred fans
came out to me, to my face,
during that meet and greet.
And for me, that was so powerful, because,
one, I know how hard that is,
and I was like wow, me being myself
did something for you.
- And you inspired them
to be confident enough to say it.
(audience applauds)
- And what better legacy,
you know, so,
that was pretty cool.
- That's the coolest.
- Thank you, thank you.